the lead-up to Star Wars Episode nine is
proving to be pretty exciting and
leading to plenty of wild speculation
strap on your helmets nerf herders
you're in for a bumpy ride as we explore
some of the latest spoilers and rumors
from a galaxy far far away Disney
decided to clean house in a big way
ahead of the force awakens declaring
that all extended universe materials
were no longer considered Star Wars
Canon the mouse house then set about
creating its own line of short stories
comics and books to tie in with the new
continuity and one such release might
just include a huge clue about a major
episode 9 character and Poe Dameron
number 27 a conversation Poe has with
Rey and Finn seems to confirm that he's
been unwittingly channeling the force
all this time
Marvel's Poe Dameron comics overlap with
JJ Abrams the force awakens
number 26 explained out Dameron survived
that crash and filled us in on what he
did between then and rescuing Rey and
Finn from the first order but it was the
following issue that really got readers
talking in it Dameron admits that he's
been able to tap into some kind of
energy while flying prompting both Ray
and Leia to suggest he's been using the
force the seeds of this reveal were
actually planted in the 2015 series Star
Wars shattered Empire
according to CBR it's in this prelude to
the force awakens that we learn how Luke
Skywalker gave remnants of the Great
Tree a natural conduit of the force to
dameron's parents who used them to grow
a new tree at home on Yavin for Dameron
even mentions growing up around this
tree further foreshadowing a connection
to the force you'll need to take this
rise of skywalker rumor with a generous
sprinkling of crates finest surface salt
because it originated from an unverified
source according to the Sun you and
McGregor will return as obi-wan kenobe
for the upcoming trilogy closer though
Disney is reportedly keen to keep that
fact under wraps
McGregor portrayed obi-wan in episodes
one through three and has already
reprised the role in voiceover form
speaking directly to Rey during a forest
vision in 2015's the force awakens he
recorded some brand new dialogue for his
brief audio cameo
which was mixed with lines from
pre-existing Star Wars movies his voice
was actually blended with that of
original obi-wan actor Alec Guinness and
more recent reports suggest that this
approach will be taken one step further
in the rise of Skywalker
according to Star Wars enthusiast Mike
zero JJ Abrams were returned to the
moment obi-wan contacted Rey in the
force awakens and flesh it out somewhat
the late Jedi Master will reportedly
appear as a force ghost his features
altered to somewhat resemble both
McGregor and Guinness and offer Ray's
some much needed guidance dominic
monaghan of lost then aliases greg
grunberg are both in the rise of
skywalker but they aren't the only
abrams alumni appearing Felicity Star
Keri Russell is also in episode 9 though
she wasn't chosen simply because she's
part of the club according to varieties
Justin Kroll Russell's experience made
her the ideal choice Kroll revealed the
role calls for action heavy fight scenes
Russell has shown her ability to perform
tough stunts and projects like FX as the
Americans Mission Impossible and dawn of
the Planet of the Apes the name of
Russell's character wasn't known at the
time but subsequent leaks shed some
light in March 2019 several
merchandising images appeared online
including one of a masked woman named
Zoe who appeared to be a new bounty
hunter bounty hunters we don't need this
fan site making Star Wars shared the
leaked pictures explaining the images
give us a good look at Zuri based on
what my sources have described to me
about Keri Russell's character I can't
see how this isn't the same character
those sources it appears were dead-on it
didn't explicitly refer to her as a
bounty hunter but Vanity Fair released
the high-res photo of Russell as quote
the masked scoundrel sorry bliss after
being granted exclusive
behind-the-scenes access to episode 9
seemingly confirming the rumors bliss
was shown unquote the thieves quarter of
snow dusted world kg me one of two new
planets and a possible entry point for
Lando Calrissian for fans of the
original trilogy one of the biggest
moments in the episode nineties er
trailer was seen Lando Calrissian back
in the cockpit to the Millennium Falcon
The Hollywood Reporter revealed that
Billy Dee
Williams was reprising the role in July
2018 but details of Calrissian sparts in
the rise of Skywalker were kept under
wraps in the months that followed early
rumours suggested that the charming
smuggler would be playing a significant
role in the saga closer but that doesn't
appear to be the case while his daughter
is rumoured to be making an appearance
Calrissian himself isn't likely to
feature very predominantly because JJ
Abrams has so much to squeeze in in
verse predicts quote Lando screen time
in the movie will be on par with Admiral
Ackbar short scenes in the force awakens
Williams kept the details of Calrissian
Sark to himself at Star Wars Celebration
2019 but he was happy to defend his
characters past actions of his divisive
betrayal of Han Solo and the Empire
Strikes Back Williams said he was up
against Darth Vader he had to figure out
something besides did anybody die he
makes a fair point but this moment has
always been a bone of contention among
fans could Calrissian who will
apparently wear the same getup he wore
when he first met solo be out to avenge
his death as a way of finally making
amends episode 9 will tie up a number of
loose ends after all one of the wildest
episode 9 rumors the theory that Han
Solo is alive is partially backed up by
the novelization of the force awakens
the book was picked apart by Uproxx and
there's a big reveal about the star
killer base that has Harrison Ford fans
speculating on an unlikely return the
book explained what the movie didn't how
the giant weapon is powered the
assumption was that had harnessed the
power of the Sun but the truth is far
more complicated Abraxas Donna Dickens
reports turns out it was never supposed
to be powered by the Sun situated in one
place messing with science they didn't
understand the first order was
harvesting dark matter to power their
weapon as the matter congealed to be
sucked into the core the light was
supposed to dim then using more science
they barely understood they beamed the
concentrated dark matter through the
galaxy instead of a cross it basically
they were ripping holes in time-space so
low appeared to have been killed by his
own Sun when we saw him last but now
there's a theoretical chance that he was
sucked into an alternate timeline before
he bled out one fan who's excited at the
prospect is director and Star Wars
fanatic Kevin Smith who tweeted if a
plot development
allows Lando to repeat his Empire
Strikes Back line there's still a chance
to save Han and get us back to that
fateful bridge on Starkiller base then
I'll kiss JJ on the mouth
numerous disgruntled Star Wars fans made
their disapproval of Rian Johnson's the
last Jedi known but the one thing that
everyone seemed to agree was done right
was the surprise appearance from Yoda
the little green Jedi Master showed up
as a force ghost to help troubled former
student Luke Skywalker come to his
senses and embrace his failures a
standout moment in the highly divisive
eighth episode Yoda was rendered in CGI
for the prequel trilogy but Johnson
chose to go back to the basics and
brought in Frank Oz to operate a
slightly updated Yoda puppet creature
designer Neil scale and said we just
felt that it was absolutely right and
proper that we create a puppet in the
closest likeness to the original and to
get Frank exactly what he had the first
time around
renowned puppeteer Oz who provides
Yoda's distinctive voice as well as his
movements could soon be adding episode 9
to his impressive resume of a new report
is to be believed according to the New
York Daily News a source with apparent
knowledge of the production has revealed
that JJ Abrams is going to bring forced
ghosts Yoda back The Insider dished the
success of the scenes featuring Yoda in
the last Jedi were huge Yoda will again
appear as a ghost as he acknowledges
Rey's success and growth as a Jedi
Lucas films original position on Carrie
Fisher's inclusion and future Star Wars
movies was pretty clear she wouldn't be
appearing in any prior to the release of
the last Jedi President Kathleen Kennedy
told ABC sadly Carrie will not be an
episode 9 the idea that they could
digitally render a version of Fisher
like they did with Peter Cushing's
Tarkin and rogue one was quickly ruled
out after execs met with Fisher's
daughter Billie lourd all parties
reportedly agreed that it would be
disrespectful at the time bringing Leia
back with unused footage from the last
Jedi was also said to have been off the
table but things have shifted since then
we now have confirmation from the late
actresses brother that Fisher will
indeed be in episode 9 with JJ Abrams
apparently set to use footage shot for
both the last Jedi and the force awakens
according to ABC's Clayton Sandell who
spoke to Todd Fisher on podcast the
resistance broadcast the family is very
happy about what Abrams has play
Sandell claimed that Todd Fisher was
quote very excited the whole family is
really excited about this and wanted it
to happen Sandell went on to explain
there are big surprises coming with this
movie and with this performance hand
with this unused footage
this one's really for the fans send l
confirmed that there is a number of
minutes worth of footage from the force
awakens and the last Jedi for Abrams to
work with when that hashtag show
reported that Disney wanted a female
lead between the ages of 40 and 50 to
play a character named Mara many jump to
the conclusion that this was Ray's
mother the character does seem to fit
the bill but now there's a fresh rumor
about Ray's mom and it's a shocker and
before you say it
no we seriously doubt that kylos take on
Rey's parents that they were nobodies
who sold her for drinking money holds
any water according to the theory posed
by film threats episode 9 we'll see
raised real mom and dad revealed to be
none other than Han Solo and Emilia
Clarke's Keira we were introduced to
Hans first love and solo a Star Wars
story a movie that could apparently end
up being all about Ray's parents film
Koretz prediction goes on to explain
solo ended letting us know that Kyra has
ties to the dark side kylo Ren is the
son of Leia a mother of the light side
Kyra a mother of the dark side Bor a
light side daughter Rey it's the forest
balancing itself of course if this
theory turns out to be accurate that
means Han cheated on Leia and fathered a
daughter with another woman while this
could actually explain a number of
things such as why kylo Ren resented his
dad so much and why he and Ray are
connected through the force not everyone
is buying it as Screen Rant points out
quote
there's been nothing to indicate han was
unfaithful to lay up the idea of Darth
Vader returning to the big screen in
episode 9 might seem ludicrous on the
surface but Disney has been subtly
paving the way for the heavy breathing
Sith Lord to play some parts in the
upcoming installment after reading
Marvel's Darth Vader comics Screen Rant
noticed one small detail that could have
actually been a huge moment too
foreshadowing the ins and outs of
becoming a force ghosts have been up for
discussion among Star Wars fans ever
since Luke Skywalker passed on in
controversial fashion near the end of
the last Jedi the assumption was that
returning as a force ghost was something
only those in tune with the light side
of
force could do but shouldn't the Sith
have their own version of this
phenomenon turns out they do and it was
explained in the pages of the Vader
comic in the story in question Vader is
gifted a mask that once belonged to
another powerful SIF called Darth mama
mom aunts residue was still attached to
the artifact when Palpatine gave it to
his third and final apprentice who used
it long story to help erect his castle
on Mustafar The Forgotten synth was able
to influence others and tell his story
to Vader via the mask screenrant's
prediction is that Vader will similarly
influence proceedings in Episode nine
seeing as his grandson kylo Ren is now
in possession of Vader's half-melted
mask with appearances on Doctor Who and
Game of Thrones under his belt veteran
character actor Richard II grants
already had some major fan cred when he
was cast in the rise of Skywalker as it
turns out he's a big star wars fan boy
himself the actor opened up about the
moment JJ Abrams told him he'd be part
of the final chapter in the Skywalker
saga while a guest on the happy sad
confused podcast revealing how he was so
excited that he couldn't actually take
anything in Grant admitted I'm sure
Abrams was telling me in detail what
part I was playing and what the
character was called I have no memory of
that whatsoever
they kept saying so you are gonna do
this aren't you and I said of course I'm
gonna do this
the most popular theory was that Grant
would be taken on the role of Grand
Admiral Thrawn a popular villain
reintroduced into the Canon in the third
season of Star Wars rebels but the actor
outright debunked that rumor when Radio
Times asked him about it
Grant dished quotes I'm not playing the
Star Wars character you just mentioned
and he wasn't lying
when Vanity Fair released a huge episode
9 cover story in made 2019 the identity
of grant's character was finally
revealed he's playing a new villain
called Allegiant general pride
despite being thrown to what we thought
was certain death by a remorseful Anakin
Skywalker in 1983's Return of the Jedi
Emperor Palpatine lives at least that's
what abrams seemed to suggest with the
first episode nineties ER the footage
ends with a shot of some death star
wreckage and Palpatine's unmistakable
cackle implying that our heroes will
face off against the powerful Sith and
the rise of Skywalker as if to confirm
this was the case puppets
actor Ian McDermott appeared onstage at
Star Wars Celebration 2019 during the
teaser reveal this was such an
unexpected moment I know it shot me
but how will abrams explain his way out
of this one theory crafters already have
a few different ideas movie web reminded
readers that in the prequel films
Palpatine has referenced dark Plagueis a
Sith Lord so powerful and wise quote he
could use the Force to influence the
midi-chlorians to create life
alternatively the site argued the
Emperor might use a loophole introduced
in Star Wars rebels the so called world
between worlds in the hidden Jedi Temple
on Lothal
apparently Palpatine quotes sought to
manipulate it as he could travel through
time by using the Force elsewhere
IGN believes that Abrams might actually
be taking some inspiration from an
expanded universe comic a dark empire
Palpatine resurrects himself several
times via clones transferring his spirit
to different bodies the first teaser for
the rise of Skywalker gave theorists
plenty to work with
now that the Emperor's presence has been
all but confirmed it's safe to assume
that he'll be involved in the film's
final battle who where and how he'll be
battling we don't know for sure but
according to making Star Wars editor
Jason Ward there's a huge rumor doing
the rounds that pits kylo Ren against
Palpatine in the form of actor Matt
Smith yep this guy this silly dude right
here the British actor has been telling
journalists that he isn't in episode 9
by that's contrary to reports even
international Disney websites are
listing the former doctor who star among
the cast and Jason Ward believes he'll
play a critical role the mega fan
reported a really solid source over the
years passed on something they heard
internally the rumor is that Matt Smith
isn't Palpatine reborn rejuvenated but a
darkside acolyte during the final act of
the film Rey and kylo team up to fight
the Palpatine possessed Matt Smith
Ward's inside source claims that kylo
Ren gets possessed by the Emperor after
killing his host body leading to a
moment of redemption the tormented son
of han Solo and Leia Organa has enough
light in him to lay down his arms so Rey
can finish the job
becoming Ben's solo again in his final
moments with Kyle
ran dead Andrade - pure for the Emperor
to possess the fight is one most fans
seemed pretty unhappy that the last Jedi
neglected the Knights of Ren kylo ren's
band of warriors appeared briefly in the
force awakens when Rey touches Luke
Skywalker's lightsaber and triggers a
vision but they were left out of Rian
Johnson's follow-up because he quote
just didn't see a place for them in the
movie
according to Vanity Fair were finally
going to get some answers in the
upcoming trilogy capper with sources at
Disney confirming theories that the
quote long rumored Knights of Ren will
finally arrive in Skywalker we got our
first good look at the unit and Annie
leibovitz's extensive photoshoot and
what's immediately clear is that they're
not your typical Star Wars villains in
contrast to the sleek and shiny look
adopted by the first-order in the
Galactic Empire before it the Knights of
Ren we're dirty ragtag armor and carry
over-the-top weapons
vanity pairs joanna robinson observed
their DIY look including one especially
lethal looking gun arm would be equally
at home in one of the Mad Max movies
their identities have not yet been
revealed though fans think they have a
pretty good idea about where they came
from in the last Jedi Luke reveals that
Ren vanished with a handful of his
padawan learners when he set the temple
ablaze and turned his back on the Jedi
did Luke's former students become the
Knights of Ren only time as they say
will tell check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff or
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]